also verschafft hat also glück so meine
frage an sie verschaffen hat weder da
sie ja noch keine kinder haben was sie
ihren kindern mal sagen werden von ihrem
job oder ob es überhaupt noch sagen
werden wie sie zu ihrem ehemaligen job
in der pornobranche stehen und ja das
würde mich interessieren dank also ich
würde da ganz klar mit der wahrheit um
die ecke kommen
bei kinder sind bei meinem mann und mir
auf jeden fall schon thema das ist halt
im moment so dass es aus beruflichen und
sagen wir mal organisatorischen gründen
jetzt gerade überhaupt nicht machbar ist
weil wir einfach so viel auf dem
programm stehen haben aber wenn es
irgendwann mal ein thema werden würde
sollte man auf jeden fall ehrlich und
offen mit der ganzen geschichte umgehen
und im grunde dem kind das sagen was ich
in dem interview und auch in jedem
anderen interview auch gesagt habe so
wie es gewesen ist